welcome to this video playing the DTI
against stefan docs coming in sort of a
match here the score is not really
improving 25% trying for on my Kings
Indians a missional now look see one is
the modern main line and Bishop d7 was
recently played against me they had
forgotten what the right move was
something like that okay okay let's
let's get for let gay let's go before
standard standard town to play in the
center 98 and f5 okay I'm preparing a
five anyway or in fact when I had this
position i applied it somewhat similarly
can even play be five now yeah maybe I
should take this chance yeah that was
clear you must do something he cannot
just wait wait until i played this on
myself the good thing for widest that i
have a somewhat to misplace the lights
are misplaced for the structure Bishop
g4 maybe continue to take only five with
the bishop and also intending Bishop
takes it to just getting rid of this
piece it's not really a useful piece yes
it's got f5 that let's move okay does
not go for that no take now and now the
nights are tremendously barely placed I
came how to improve it I mean some way
to improve that takes Bishop takes Jim I
would like to get one of the nights to
d7 if it was the night on d7 are
instantly in good shape I mean in really
good shape but it is simply not the case
obviously okay don't really see what
else Knight f6 is playing e5
ok maybe not be 67 I mean there is
always this possibility for him to play
if either maybe as a pawn sec even Amit
it's not it does not seem to work at the
moment so it might be that I really get
to e5 yep I manage that what I wasn't so
sure if this is necessary ok um yeah f6
I really don't want to play and even I
rather prefer to give up an exchange
then then play of six Bishop d7 95
should be decent compensation it's not
going for that even ok yeah maybe maybe
a good decision a key is trying to to
fight for the e5 square
93 coming yeah going for total blockade
here
and then they look over
you know it should be okay I mean it's
is somewhat more active but I don't
think I should lose the position where
he has stable very stable set up the
night only eight however is not great I
wonder if there's some way to improve it
probably see 7 a-8 be 67 something like
that takes a while but ok yeah here the
question is to do I let's just just
allow him to take it it's no no big deal
I want this Bishop only five I mean is
just much stronger than any any minor
piece and the night will help on d 7
this should be ok i think maybe m-maybe
you can go to he manages to go to e6
sounders this as possible
queen is 726
probably miss if I go nite F age he will
play night Quincy aid okay this is maybe
not the end of the world Wow
and he's got the cs got air five
immediately time warning
and now 1970s got rookie six
now you five that's the problem ok we
can even improve now but this is the
easiest
another segment Roxy aids made checkmate
hmm so hard to believe that black should
lose this really like almost a totem
locate but just exactly like that it is
winning I mean yeah just like this is
just just the problem I mean I just need
one move like age six and then this this
is a total blockade I came maybe I
should should have moved the rook away
within there's also G hi yeah not not
much to do here I mean this this type of
position is of course a tad passer for
black that's clear but still it's it's
very resilient but maybe I need to
improve the night night someone quicker
not sure the defect or the the thing why
I still think this should be somewhat
okay is this dead bishop on d3 of course
black is somewhat passive that's clear
but this is a nice piece and d3 is
really just terribly bad if I get the
light some more involved then it
shouldn't be too bad I mean it's a
question if I play this is this winning
for wine I mean really like this just
just very very passive he's got a 3m mmm
tell ya how to tell me it was just too
passive alright thanks for watching